- I guess if you have an addiction in life
it's nice to have one like curiosity.
I am not going to figure
out where to drive the bus
until I've got the
right people on the bus.
Not only that, 15 of the
18 built to last companies
lived through the 1930s depression.
I can remain focused on and suffer for
the big thing longer than anyone else.
And I'm about to fall,
I'm 400 feet above the ground.
Please turn off your electronic gadgets.
But what was Intel known for?
Intel delivers.
See, if you have the right people
they're already motivated.
The question is not risk or not risk,
the question is where do
you place your big bets.
I'm genetically encoded to do it,
when I do it I feel like a fish in water.
- He's an American business consultant,
author, and lecturer.
- He's a student and a
teacher of leadership.
- He's authored or coauthored six books
that have sold over 10
million copies worldwide.
- He's Jim Collins, and here are his
top 10 rules for success.
- I guess if you have an addiction in life
it's nice to have one like curiosity.
I mean, questions for me
are where everything begins
and always like to describe it that
I don't pick questions,
in many ways they pick me.
They kind of rise up and grab
around the throat and say
I'm not going to let go.
And to me life is just a journey
of question upon question,
and there's so many chances
to learn things.
One of my mentors, John Gardner,
who was in the Johnson administration,
was a senior faculty at Stanford.
- Wrote about excellence.
- Wrote about excellence
truly before people
were thinking about it, and
renewal, and self renewal,
and John had this
wonderful way of saying it,
don't try to be
interesting, be interested.
And that stuck with me,
and this idea of always be interested,
and you never know where
a question will go,
you sit down with somebody
and you ask a simple question
like where are you from?
So think about the power of that question,
where are you from?
That's not a hierarchical question,
that's not a question of what do you do
or how important are you,
it's where are you from?
And somebody can choose,
it's an invitation,
well, I'm from Virginia,
or I'm from Greece,
or I'm from, they can name
their company, they can choose,
and the interesting
thing is you never know
where that will go.
And then in actual work it all
has to begin with questions
because if you actually know the answers
then I don't understand the
point of doing the work.
When Dick Cooley became chief
executive of Wells Fargo
in the late 1970s he
knew he would be facing
the storm of deregulation,
he knew that the entire
banking industry would be upended
when deregulation swept through.
The board, understandably concerned,
asked Cooley, what is your vision,
what is your strategy,
where will you lead us,
how will you get us through
this storm of deregulation?
And Cooley had a wonderful answer,
I don't know.
Not only that, it's the wrong question.
See, I am not going to first figure out
where to drive this bus and
then get people on the bus.
No, I'm going to do it
completely opposite.
I am not going to figure
out where to drive the bus
until I've got the
right people on the bus.
And only once I've got the
right people on the bus,
the wrong people off the bus,
and the right people on the key seats,
then and only then will I turn
my attention to the question
of where we will drive this bus.
The best executives we've studied
always think first about who
and then about what.
It's not about just getting a great team,
it's not about finding talent,
it's not about getting great people, no.
The key word is first.
First get right people,
first get the people on the bus,
first think about who,
put who up ahead of strategy,
who ahead of tactics,
who ahead of technology,
who ahead of business ideas,
who ahead of everything.
First who, first who,
first who, then what.
I mentioned earlier
the work built to last.
It was very interesting,
we were studying enduring
great companies in contrast to others,
went back recently and realized
we selected the study set
for that study in 1989,
two decades ago.
All 18 of the built to last companies
are still standalone, independent,
and almost all of them
very successful companies today.
If you took a random sample
of large publicly traded
companies 20 years ago,
what are the probabilities
that all 18 in your random
sample would be standalone,
independent, and largely
successful today, the number is less,
it's a percentage, is
about .02% probability.
Not only that, 15 of the
18 built to last companies
lived through the 1930s depression.
What did they teach us?
What has enabled them to have that?
What did we find that separated them?
And what we found is that
what really separated them
was not necessarily that
they had smarter strategies,
although they often did,
or that they were sort of
more financially savvy,
although they often were.
It was because they were
founded first and foremost
and built always on a rock
solid set of core values
that are not open for negotiation.
And if you look at what gave
them the reason to struggle,
the reason to fight, the reason to endure,
it wasn't strategic, it was values.
One of the greatest, probably
the greatest rock climber
of his generation, as you
know I've been a climber
most of my life, is actually right now
on the side of El Capitan
doing what will probably be
the hardest rock climb certainly
ever done in our lifetimes,
trying to free climb a
thing called the Don Wall,
Mesolito side of El Cap,
young man named Tommy Caldwell
who is, he's in a category of one.
And I was out climbing with
Tommy one day and I said to him,
Tommy, what makes you different?
He has a record, he has
six climbs on El Cap
that have never been repeated.
He's just, he is 10x
in extreme environments
and he's still alive.
I said, Tommy, what is it that you have,
you're not necessarily
more physically gifted,
you're not necessarily stronger,
you're certainly physically
gifted and all those things
but you're not this incredible athlete
that just was born this way.
And in fact he'd lost a
finger in an accident,
he cut a finger off,
and so he's doing this
minus one of his.
- An important finger?
- An important finger.
And he thought about it
for one moment and he said,
I can remain focused on and suffer for
the big thing longer than anyone else.
And I think that's what they do,
the curiosity keeps them
going but once they get their
hands on what they see is
the thing they don't let go
and they can stay with
it and suffer for it.
When I was in high school I must've been
maybe 16 or 17 years old
and I went rock climbing
in El Dorado Canyon
near where I grew up in Boulder.
I've been climbing about
three or four years
and went to do a climb called T2.
Now at the time, T2 is a
relatively difficult climb
and I went at it with a kind
of arrogant lack of preparation
and I hadn't prepared for being able to do
certain kinds of finger cracks,
I figured I'll figure
it out when I get there,
and I also didn't pause,
and this is that thing
about boldness and
discipline, I didn't pause
to really double check all my systems.
So I'm on the fourth pitch,
I'm about 400 feet above the ground,
I'm going across this
slanting crack system
that I started to have trouble with
and by forearm started
to engorge with blood
and lactic acid, which means at some point
even if you're on a big hold
your hands are going to melt off.
And I'm about to fall,
I'm 400 feet above the ground,
but it should be okay
because there's protection,
I'm tied into the rope, I may take a fall
but I'll get caught.
For some reason, and to this
day I still don't know why,
my brain triggered that
I should look at my knot.
And I looked down at my knot,
my knot had come untied.
I had made the mistake of
never really thinking about
the best knot for certain
types of situations
and I tied it with what's a bowline.
Now the advantage of a
bowline is it's easy to untie,
the disadvantage of a bowline
is it's easy to untie.
It had come untied as I kept moving across
and it it just hanging in my harness.
I'm seconds away from
falling, only now I will die.
I will die if I fall off.
My forearms are melting
and the knot had come
untied, and so I call down
to my partner and I said,
my knot came untied,
what is he going to do,
he can't do anything,
he'll just watch me fall to my death.
And there was an old
fixed piton in the rock
that was put there from the first descent,
an old soft iron piton,
and I looked at it,
and I probably had 15, 20
seconds before my hands
would unwrap, if that, maybe 10.
I took a runner and I
clipped it into the piton
and I clipped that runner into my harness
and just went, please hold, and I let go.
And it held.
I put in a backup, I
grabbed the knot, retied it,
went to the ledge, I didn't convulse,
I was very calm at that
moment, when I got to the ledge
I went into convulsive shaking,
I was sick to my stomach
for days because of
what happens chemically.
What I learned from that is two things.
The first is that when you're
in an unforgiving world,
gravity is unforgiving, it doesn't care,
it never takes a day off, ever,
and if you make one
mistake it can kill you
if it's the wrong kind of mistake,
and what I learned is that
sense of, yeah, I want to do
adventurous things, I want to climb rocks,
I want to be in Yosemite,
I want to do things
that get my adrenaline going,
but I need the discipline
to always do all the right preparation,
to always think about the right knots,
to always be cross checking
my system so that I can
do those bold things and stay alive
in an unforgiving environment,
and as you and I spoke about
earlier today, I think that's the recipe,
I think we are all heading
into an unforgiving environment
where we're going to have to
be both bold and disciplined.
The second thing I learned,
what if that piton had not been there?
We might not be here together.
It was just by chance that
that piton was right there.
And what you realize
when you rewind the tape
of your own life is that there
are these crucial moments
where if the luck had gone the other way
you might have gotten killed.
And so what you have to do is to always be
putting those extra discipline in place
because I was lucky to live,
and what I took from that
is I never want to have
to be lucky to live again.
I want to live because of my discipline
not because of my luck.
Please turn off your electronic gadgets.
Not for others but for yourself.
Effective people take time to think.
Begin the discipline
of putting white space
on your calendar where
there's no phone, no email,
I was going to say no fax
but they don't even have that
anymore, no Twitter, no
emails, no connections,
and engage in this
glorious pockets of quiet.
Do you know that Rick Warden
reads a book every single day?
A book a day.
A book a day, 365 days a year.
You're at a thousand books in three years.
First, innovation is extremely important
and I would not want
to send any indication,
we should stop innovating and
America shouldn't innovate,
that'd be inaccurate.
- Well, we better damn well
understand what made us
innovative and make sure
we don't lose those things.
- Exactly right, we can't
afford to lose those things.
What we found is that any
given industry has a threshold
level of innovation and
that once you get to that,
you have to get to that threshold.
For something like airlines
it's relatively low
and for something like
biotech it's really high.
But once you meet that
threshold of innovation
it's not innovation alone
that makes you exceptional,
it is actually the blend
of being able to put
the innovation plus the
organizational discipline.
Again, we go back to was Apple
just an innovation story?
No, at some point it was a
whole bunch of other things
around it that made it work.
If we go back and we look at Intel,
what was Intel known for?
Well, yes, it had a lot of
innovation because to be
in semiconductor industry
you had to have a lot
of innovation, but were they
always the most innovative, no.
And at critical junctures
they might even have been
a little bit behind, but
what was Intel known for?
Intel delivers.
So, you are IBM, what's
your worst nightmare?
You don't have enough
chips at affordable cost
when the time comes, and you
can look at different kinds,
you got maybe one chip this
morning that's innovative
but you've got another chip
that's innovative enough
but it's got the organization
behind it with the discipline
and it delivers, where
are you going to bet?
- It delivers.
- It delivers, exactly right.
I've always loved the
story Silver Blaze which is
the Sherlock Holmes story
where at the end of the case
the constable asks Holmes,
what was the key to the case,
and Holmes says, it was
the curious incident
of the dog in the nighttime.
And the constable says, but
the dog didn't do anything
in the nighttime.
Ah ha, yes, that was the curious incident,
the dog didn't bark, and so
therefore I knew the criminal
must've been somebody who knew the dog.
In our research
it is the dogs that do not bark
that often give us some of the best clues.
And the dogs that do
not bark helped us see
the who principle.
Now you would think that
if you're leading a company
from good to great, one of
the things you would expect
to see, one of the dogs
you would expect to bark,
is that you would find very
motivating and charismatic
leaders who could infuse
motivation into the troops
so that they would go out
and do good to great things.
Well, as our research
unfolded what we found is that
most of the good to great leaders had had
a charisma bypass.
They couldn't motivate
anybody out of just a
pure motivational force,
that's not how they led.
But then when we began asking them,
how did you get alignment, how did you get
people motivated behind
what you were trying to do?
The dog just didn't bark.
They didn't spend any time on that.
That's not how they led.
And we scratched our heads a little bit,
how would you make sense of the fact that
you're getting a whole
company to go in a different
direction and yet the
leaders who made this happen
didn't invest in figuring
out how to motivate people,
how to inspire people, how to get people
behind the flywheel.
And this is where we learned something.
See, if you have the right people
they're already motivated.
The right people are self motivated.
The right people are self disciplined.
And the challenge of management,
the challenge of leadership
is not how to figure out how
to motivate the wrong people
into the right people,
it's how to get the right
people and then not do
all the stupid management
things that tend to
demotivate the already motivated people.
- So what you also talked
about in your book is
not to take big risks, not to,
you said, fire cannonballs.
- Yeah, well you want to fire cannonballs,
so this is the really interesting thing,
the fire bullets then fire cannonballs,
it's not a matter of, the
question is not risk or not risk,
the question is where do
you place your big bets
cause if you don't place a big bet
then you're never
actually going to achieve
exceptional results, if
you're never really going big.
The question is how do
you place your big bets
and bound your risk at the same time,
and there the answer is,
what we found is that
all of our companies
and all of our leaders
did place big bets but
they placed them after
they had proven that they had
taken most of the risk out
by proving that that bet
would likely pay off.
The uncalibrated cannonball is dangerous,
the calibrated cannonball is
how you get something great.
If you think about sort of
how people apply themselves,
when we go back and we look
at the good to great data
and some of the other data, we find that
there's these three circles
and you put your energies
in the middle of three circles.
And the first circle is
what you're passionate about
and what you love to do
and what you stand for.
And the second circle is
what you can be the best at,
and the third circle is what
drives your economic engine.
And you focus your energies there,
but let's drop that down
a level to the individual.
How many of the folks under age 30 in here
have had cross your mind the thought,
I wonder what I'm going to do with myself.
(laughter)
Okay, I'd like you to think then about
finding your own three circles,
at an individual level,
which is think about it this way,
imagine that you could engage
your energies and your time
directly in the middle of three tess.
First, it is something for
which you have great passion,
that you love to do, and
that absolutely reflects
your values, and when you
wake up in the morning
there's this sense of,
my goodness, even if
I'm getting paid for this,
I would want to do it
even if I wasn't getting paid for it.
Now imagine if in addition to that
you could marry it to a second circle
which is finding what you're
genetically encoded for.
And there's a big difference
of what you're good at
and what you're genetically encoded for.
I discovered this as a young person.
I went off to college,
I thought I would be
a mathematician, I had
done well on math tests,
but when I entered
courses like Real Analysis
I met those who were
genetically encoded for math.
(laughter)
Not being one of them I
needed to find another version
of my three circles.
(laughter)
And now imagine the third circle.
As you're engaged in something
that makes, that is of great value.
It's of either social or
economic or both of value,
it makes a contribution, you are useful.
Now imagine you have all three.
Man, I'm passionate about
this, I love to do it,
it expresses my values, I'm
genetically encoded to do it,
when I do it I feel like a fish in water,
and then finally, third, I'm useful.
What percentage of the
world do you think has that?
Five percent?
Maybe not even.
What would happen to the world if,
let's say it's three percent,
if we then made it 20%
of people who are doing what
they're passionate about,
genetically encoded for, and are useful,
are in positions of real
contribution and value.
Now I don't know the answer
of how we make that percentage
go up, but linking back
to the idea of Maslow,
how did he describe self actualization?
It wasn't hanging out on the beach.
(laughter)
He defined self
actualization as discovering
what you were meant to do
and committing to the ardor of
pursuing it with excellence.
The purpose of free
society, I would suggest,
is to systematically increase
the percentage of people
who do exactly that.
And then they can do it for
very long periods of time.
- Thank you so much for watching.
- We made this video
because Arnos asked us to.
If there is anyone that you
would like us to feature
please leave a comment below.
- We'd also love to know
which of Jim Collins's
top 10 rules meant the most to you,
leave it in the comments below
and we'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching,
continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.